[Music]
[Music]
please welcome our guest speaker the
only person we could afford professional
fantasy football player Matt camp
so you graduated to college big deal the
work starts now I won weeks one and two
and then sake won Berkeley went down
some of you graduated magna [ __ ] laude so
what did you beat a Lamar Jackson led
fantasy team with Brandon Allen I did
here's what I recommend don't look for a
job today tomorrow focus on the fantasy
playoffs let's be honest
you'll all be moving back in with your
parents anyway but that championship
pride that will live forever in closing
I'd like to say two things number one
establish the run and number two no
matter what you do after you graduate
it's time right now for your fantasy
fire drill
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
bad
line up you can do it come on keep it up
good job buddy welcome in it's your
fantasy fire drill I am mad camp and
this is it this is very likely the last
week of your fantasy regular season
we're gonna make it happen with the
playoff push welcome into Caesars the
sports book in Las Vegas welcome into
your fantasy fire drill join us every
single Sunday morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30
Pacific on all bleacher report platforms
I'll get to plenty of your questions
throughout the show YouTube I got you as
always and as soon as the show is over
I'll jump in the app for another 30
minutes to take your questions what are
we getting - of course inactives
ins and outs we'll get to that in just a
couple of seconds here I'll give you my
sleepers for week 13 the jump off this
week will be about fantasy defenses you
might be on your way to the playoffs
already congratulations for clinching
look-ahead forget the dead spots you
need to line up maybe pick up a second
defense for weeks 14 through 16 I'll
give you three options later on in the
show and our matte moment why you got to
be careful about the trust all of that
coming your way but right now let's get
to those injuries what do we know right
now for inactives as they drop we will
bring them to you and we'll give you
updates throughout the show here's our
early games right now juju is out again
for the Steelers we know that don't feel
necessarily great about their passing
attack duck is getting the look by the
way duck Hodges will start for the
Steelers tonight James Conner I don't
have them officially yet very likely not
out there we'll talk about a running
back to graph from the Steelers that you
can play as a sleeper this week Evan
Ingram's out golden Tate's out this week
- Giants are down
sterling Shepherd to me is a wide
receiver three by the way know ret else
and either and we'll find out just how
healthy say Quan Barkley is he does have
a good matchup at least by the numbers
against the Green Bay Packers today's
Eckert's is gonna be in today there you
go for the Philadelphia Eagles we love
playing him I still have doubts got it
at my top 10 but one Eagle we know is
out today and that is Jordan Howard now
Nelson Aguilar and Alshon Jeffery are
off the injury report I don't really
care too much about them Jeffrey's a
wide receiver three but I will tell you
that I think mild Sanders has a top 15
weaken him he might be the key player
taking on the Miami Dolphins today so
play him with confidence
CY Hilton
Oh Marlon Mac no they're both down today
Jonathan Williams is clearly the guy in
the backfield he's got a top 15 weaken
him again I believe that and I'll say
this I don't feel good about the
receivers report this morning Devin
Funchess not gonna come back this year
so caught him loose he's not a stash
away guy but I will tell you this with
Eric Ebron landing on the IR just a few
days ago I love Jack Doyle today and for
the rest of the season t white Hilton
and Eric Ebron came into this week
leading the team tied at the top in
target share that's a big number that
gets vacated Jack Doyle can pick that up
Chris Thompson here for the Redskins
banged up we don't have the information
on that one yet Matt burrito will be out
today I can tell you that
so Tevin Coleman a low-end RB to Darius
guys coming back to the Redskins is a
flex play at best
that's where at with our early games
we'll revisit that we could fill in all
the gaps a little bit later on here's
what we know for later on today and
tomorrow night Gerald Everett is out
this week hunter Renfro is down this
week for Everett look I know
pigby that's your thought he's got the
Cardinals he's a deep deep deep sleeper
at best only because the Rams aren't
playing well I know the Cardinals match
it was one of the best in the business
Renfro being down certainly hurts the
offense as a whole for the Raiders but I
do think Tyrell Williams will benefit
with more targets and Josh Jacobs could
be a busy man in that game as well very
likely to get over a thousand yards in
his rookie season with today's game
Damian Williams is out for the Chiefs
today so you're playing McCoy with
confidence as an rb2 and if you have
Darryl Williams I think there's some
value to that why he's on the Chiefs we
like getting pieces of good offenses a
Dorsett Edelman and Mohamed Sanu one of
like the 32 percent of the Patriots or
those guys are in that group of guys
that were on the injury report but
they're all expected to play Adelman's
the only one you're considering at all
now Adam Thielen could be back tomorrow
against the Seahawks it's not a lock and
Kyle Rudolph is not gonna appear in the
sleepers on the board later but he was
in Friday's article because why he has
been the one who's benefited the most
from the absence of feeling he has come
through as a pretty reliable fantasy
tight end if Thielen were to come back
that would hurt him a little bit Lockett
and Hollister should be able to go on
Monday night but as we said we don't
know right now so maybe you throw these
guys in your Flex spot just to give
yourself a little protection if you have
the pivot elsewhere but now we'll get to
your questions and we'll get to plenty
of these throughout the show today what
do you have for me I'm here to help
Oh should I haven't feel and still be
started even with the risk he may be out
good question I want the chance to start
Adam feeling so I put in my Flex that
way if he doesn't go my pivot to oh I
don't know Rashad penny I pivot to
Alexander Madison I can go elsewhere I
pivot to Kyle Rudolph if I need to you
want every opportunity if you can't do
that you can't risk the zero when it
comes to Adam feeling need to tight end
got hurt pygmy or John Oh
I'm gonna go got it I think he's
probably the number two option right now
in the Eagles offense in terms of the
passing game behind Zach Ertz fighting
for first pick to Snell Williams or
Slaton I think I'll sit Slaton there yes
we don't have Tate yes we don't have
Ingram but I don't love the matchup
against the Packers defense role Chris
Carson after last week er start wish
Colt McCoy I'm gonna go with Carson he's
a better player I'm not too worried
about him I know the fumbles are there
yeah we could see some of penny but it's
not like McCoy's been lighting it up
either so we're gonna go with Kris
Carson hope for the best their start
Darryl Williams Rashad Penny very
similar situation I'll take the better
offense I'll go with Darryl Williams
just because I feel like he's got a
better chance of touches than Rashad
penny one good game does not make Rashad
penny a fantasy superstar Rogers were
Jameis we're gonna play Aaron Rodgers
against the Giants and do so with a lot
of confidence more your questions coming
up but people got up early and they came
out to watch us here this Sunday morning
so I go out into the sports book to help
them and we're gonna do so right now
come on in here sir what's your name
hazel hazel how can I help you good and
this is the last week of fantasy and I
don't know who to put on my flag all
right I need this win and all I carry
Fitzgerald versus the Rams
or we gonna put Tyler Higbee versus
Arizona since they letting up a lot of
points right tight ends or we're going
with Ryan Griffin he's been the high hat
Ryan Griffin's the man right now and he
has gone from sleeper to starter for me
I think he's gonna help you win today's
got the Bengals I know the higbie thing
I get it but chargaff's not playing too
good Sam Donald is we'll talk more about
Sam Donald you gonna get that win you go
to the playoffs all right yeah they go
hey no I'm going to play off PJ you're
not going to the playoffs let's write PJ
that's for you there's hazel he's
win this week and so are you here's your
map moment love football bloopers but
what about all the ridiculous press
conferences with this new VHS tape
football press conference bloopers you
get all your favorites like this week
one doozy from Bengals coach Zack Taylor
yeah I think we'll have AJ green back
before we know it this whopper from
bears coach Matt Nagy I have full
confidence in this offense we also have
owners like Jerry Jones is the coach to
lead this team to the Super Bowl
this John Mara Lambie I hope Eli has a
great season and he plays all year
football minds like Bill Polian
no doubt about it Lamar Jackson will be
better as a wide receiver act now and
you'll get some of the best from 2019
like this laugher from Kliff Kingsbury
yeah David Johnson is fine football
press conference blueprint all the funny
stuff without any of that pesky football
[Laughter]
you haven't figured it out by now you
can't trust these coaches or GM's or
pundants sometimes be included in that
but what I'm telling you is read between
the lines say Pub Barclays fine he's
going to be good to go you see this
production it has been good AJ Green
will be back we're still waiting Amari
Cooper's had two MRIs in the last month
you're not gonna tell me he's fine I
don't care if the guy's not on the
injury report these are things we have
to read between the lines of is the
fantasy production there
Oh David Johnson in the back and no he's
not he's he's useless now for fantasy so
think about that as you're setting your
lineups don't trust these coaches I hate
to tell you they don't care about your
fantasy team but I do so I will read
between the lines and I will help you
DTA a bald smart guy once said that once
then want a bunch of world titles I'm
gonna tell you can win a fantasy
championship by using the very same
mantra DTA don't trust those guys don't
trust anybody but trust me because now I
got your week 13 sleepers
[Music]
all right what do we want to happen we
want sleepers to graduate into starters
but if we don't get that that's fine
we'll just take one week one week at a
time is not a bad way to go you can get
one player that gives you a boost
because there's an injury and
opportunity out there and we're gonna
talk about that right now with these
three sleepers by the way the sleeper
article comes out every Friday get the
full list so you can get a jump on the
waiver wire but we have you covered
right now with these sleepers we're
gonna start in the Pittsburgh backfield
with Benny Snell now James Conner
certainly injured again we knew that
though but Benny Snell last week led the
Steelers and carries and snaps they
don't seem to have any interest in
making Jalen Samuels the guy to handle
the lion's share of the carries and I
don't blame the Steelers for doing so he
can cash it he's their past catcher but
Benny Snell seems to be the guy who's
gonna get those calories today against
the Cleveland Browns the fight for the
north or whatever the hell they're
calling it even though the Ravens are
far better than both of those teams
whatever
Benny Snell from a vol standpoint is a
good flex with potential RB to
production for week number 13 now let's
move on from Benny Snell let's go to a
quarterback who you might go well
doesn't this go against your mantra of
staying away from bad teams it does
however the Jets are on a three-game
winning streak
much like the Jets to ruin their draft
value by winning meaningless games but
the bottom line is they're playing good
football and young-sam darn 'old not Sam
Bradford which I call him all the time
Sam darn 'old is getting the job done
with Ryan Griffin with Jameson Crowder
and he's got the Bengals today a very
beatable matchup
Donald hit big last week I think he's
got another top ten potential week in
him this week so yes it's okay to stream
your quarterbacks it works out quite
nicely now one more here for you of our
sleepers for this week and we love to
take advantage of matchups the
Jacksonville Jaguars take on the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers today DJ dark top five
wide receiver loved edy Westbrook but I
also love this guy Chris Conley might be
the number three wide receiver for the
Jacksonville Jaguars but he's averaging
about seven targets per game over the
last four weeks Nick Foles is throwing a
bunch of passes and should do the same
today against the Buccaneers why it's
the best matchup four wide receivers by
the numbers over the last month and for
the entire season
we love following the narrative of bad
defenses
the narrative is that the Buccaneers
defense stinks against wide receivers
need a little boost take a shot on Chris
Conley this week those are your sleepers
take a look at Nick Foles take a look at
Kyle Rudolph as well a couple more
options for you that we're in the Friday
article but now we get some more of your
questions here for week 13 and
potentially beyond if you're already
locked into the playoffs Melvin Gordon
or Jonathan Williams nice spot to be in
can we leave we're asking this question
I'm gonna stick with Melvin Gordon I'm
gonna play the talent of Melvin Gordon
today against the Broncos next up here
mark Anders or Ryan Griffin nice spot to
be in mark Andrews is in your lineup one
of the most consistent players not just
a tight end but in all of fantasy
football this year we're gonna play Mark
Andrews later on today a half point PPR
first playoff game welcome into the
playoff start Chris Carr Thunder miles
Sanders I'll say Carson's a little bit
safer in terms of guarantee touches to
me Sanders is your up side play if you
think you need it if you're a big
underdog taking of the Dolphins not a
bad option at all I can see why you're
in the playoffs of that team Colin
barrier nick foles not sure if Murray's
injury all indicate starts good to go I
haven't met like six or seven of my
rankings a few spots ahead of Nick Foles
we're gonna play Kyler Murray today with
confidence against the Rams need to
Barkley Williams Hunter Sanders cookers
Marber you want I can't sit sake 1 I
understand why you're asking but I can't
sit sake 1 so we're gonna play Barkley
and I'll play Myles Sanders this week I
like him against the Dolphins I think
you could be the Eagles most important
player I need to win to make the
playoffs running back and flex Carson
Jones Sanders obj my goodness I'm gonna
tell you to play backup we're gonna go
there you can play the upside of Sanders
you can go safe of Carson once again
comes down to what you think your
matchups gonna be there you go those are
your questions for right now we go to
the wall for a viewer question hey Matt
Daniel Mahaveer here a question for you
which Chiefs running back would you take
for the rest of the season
very interesting question I'm not gonna
be ASEA there's not an answer here
there's not a clear answer because there
hasn't been a clear answer basically all
season remember when they had Carlos
Hyde in Kansas City then they had McCoy
I warned you about Damian Williams
preseason he's out today we've seen
Darrell Williams come in we've seen
McCoy look good look bad he might be the
guy today this is a week-to-week
proposition and this goes against the
three of Andy Reid is typically stuck
with one guy he just doesn't have that
guy this year so they have made
adjustments its McCoy today it could be
Darryl Williams in the future it could
be a little Darryl Williams today I just
don't think there's one singular answer
to give you so I'm not gonna tell you
that guy we are security of the worst
people are going down on the stage the
security is the worst here but what I
can tell you is we're gonna prepare you
for the fantasy playoffs the jump off
this week is about fantasy deepen the
jump ball
the jump ball still the jump ball to
jump off okay here's the deal if you
have already clinched the fantasy
playoffs first of all congratulations
you clearly watch this show so good job
to you but don't worry about the empty
depth in your roster you're looking at
players right now on the back end your
roster I've never used these guys and
get the most use out of your entire
roster by that I mean add a second
defense take a look at the matchups
we're gonna do that right now I'm gonna
give you three defenses that I think you
can mix and not I'm not saying use them
for the whole fantasy playoffs but take
advantage of the matchups and do so by
getting ahead on the waiver wire so you
don't have to fight during that
particular week so our first defense is
the Dallas Cowboys now why are the
Cowboys on here probably just a solid
defense at Chicago like that home
against the Rams and at Philadelphia
those are 14 15 and 16 games so there's
pretty good matchups there there's no
offenses that scare you
that is a contending team besides the
fact their coach stinks but there are
good matchups tears that you could take
advantage of now the next defense or
next team I should say of defenses we're
talking about is the Detroit line so
once again I know they're not that good
I'm not saying that we're mixing and
matching at Minnesota okay forget that
game home against Tampa Jameis Winston's
a turnover machine and then at Denver
they're starting drew lock today for
God's sakes so there's two matchups
there in 15 and 16 there you go well
that defense is not very good but the
matchups are great so they're you're
mixing matching again and you might use
Detroit with the Green Bay Packers who
are third and final defense based on
their 14 15 and 16 weeks of schedule why
home against Washington we like that
home against the Bears we like that and
then at Minnesota week 16 you stay away
from so there you go there's a way to
interlock the Packers and the Lions use
both defenses all I'm saying is if
you're clinched who cares about what's
on the backi roster that you're never
gonna start use those spots or spot for
a second defense then you don't have to
fight on the waiver wire later on that
is your jump off for this week good luck
key and the fantasy playoffs if you've
already clinched but now we get two more
and out let's do that right now sorry
we'll get some questions first then
we'll get the ins and outs Melvin Gordon
playing Denver we're Kenyan Drake
playing a weak Aram defense no I'm not
telling you to sit Melvin Gordon for
Kenyan big I'll never do that
Calvin Elton Gord is still a tough
matchup for the Denver defense as well
next up here Lockett or DD Westbrook you
have to make this call today you have to
play Westbrook because we do not know
for sure that locket is playing if you
can get both in and flex lock it maybe
try to do that but if you don't know you
can't miss the 0 especially not today
McAfee our cook who has that question
how is that even possible
McCaffrey your cook get out of your to
team League I'm not answering that keep
going
DJ more keen Allen another one here what
are these who are these leagues I'm
gonna tell you to play Keenan Allen I
trust his quarterback more as simple as
that even though I don't think that
we're gonna bench rivers anytime soon
next up here Jarvis Landry or Tyler boy
I do like Landry a lot today against the
Pittsburgh Steelers
even though Andy Dalton's back the red
rocket will not help Tyler Boyd out all
that much next Edelman or cup oh this is
tough and I've been a big cup guy all
year I just trust that Ulm in Moore
right now I can't believe I'm saying
that
let's go to the wall for a celebrity
question ah hell Malcolm Bivens here
business manager and publicists to the
stars
and yes Matt can't behalf agreed to do
your show not because I like you but
only for the free publicity and I am
also here with a very special guest and
Matt it seems like he doesn't like you
but that's normal because most people
don't like you I'm here to announce that
Bivens enterprises we are expanding
expanding it to the NFL another
franchise I can't wait to take over but
Matt question who should I start
Sterling Shepherd or Dede Westbrook
I know it wasn't free he had to pay for
that I'm gonna make sure Malcolm Bivens
pay for that by the way his jacket look
like he blown the jump off video alright
I'm answering this question not for
Malcolm Bivens for you because I've
gotten in a lot this week
sterling Shepherd with no Golden Tate
Evan Engram yes he looks good against
the Packers but DD Westbrook looks a
heck of a lot better against the best
possible matchup four wide receivers
against Tampa Bay Buccaneers Jaguars are
throwing a lot I expect to see more of
that today so I will tell Malcolm and
the world to play a DD Westbrook Malcolm
Bivens on the show get out of here
alright let's get to your ins and outs
not the Bivens on the inactives but
here's what we know right now
juju Smith Shuster is out as we know and
of course James Connor is out so yes we
do like Benny Snell today I have an
Ingram Golden Tate down Sheppard's our
wide receiver three will see a sake one
Barkley can come through him by the way
if he's truly not hurting okay he should
do well against they beatable Packers
are on defense Zach Ertz is in but
Jordan Howard is out I think this is a
mild Sanders game all the way still like
Goddard as a top ten tight end obviously
like hurts as well Jeffrey's a wide
receiver three at ey Hilton's down so is
Marlon Mac like Jonathan Williams really
like Jack Doyle Eric Ebron lands on the
IR this week Chris Thompson's in more of
a nuisance takes away some of the
confidence in terms of using one Darius
guys and then map Rita as we know is out
today so it's Evan Coleman low end RB to
revisiting our late-game and actives and
tomorrow's games as we bring these up
here
Gerald Everett's down you want to reach
real deep and go for Tyler Higbee I get
it the Cardinals against tight ends is
usually a goldmine
you gotta rely on Jared Goff hunter
renfro's down more targets for Josh
Jacobs more targets for Tyrell Williams
today which is not a bad thing they mean
Williams is down so Darryl Williams has
some flex appeal and you play McCoy as
an RB to your set Edelman Mohamed Sanu
all expected to play against the Texans
later on Edelman's your guy only one you
can really trust Adam feeling Lockett in
Hollister all questionable we don't know
for sure so once again if you don't have
other options in this game you may not
want to risk the 0 but that's up to you
I don't like to do so not a lot that any
of these guys are out there but what I
can tell you is that I'm gonna get to a
bunch of questions right now this
your speed round
[Music]
13th time we're doing this will it be
the charm coach every week's the charm a
because speed round I don't got anything
else just put on their headband and he
is out of material folks but go see
Little Women all right let's get to the
speed round there goes the IFV but I got
you covered here
Tannehill or whence a six-point
touchdown link I'm gonna go went by a
little bit there I think he's got a
pretty good game coming next up here
what do we got Lockett Oh BJ slate in
Washington we'll go lock it and Oh BJ
obviously we know about the injury but
I'll take the chance on them with those
other options there next up winter go
home worried about Chris Carson's start
him Westbrook er guys if you want to
play the up side of Westbrook I have no
problem taking that shot to take a bunch
of targets are coming in his way as we
know a great matchup against the
Buccaneers next up here Tyrell Williams
or Chris Conley Williams is a little bit
safer if you need the upside if you're
down big from Thursday I'm okay playing
the upside of Connelly but Williams is
the safer play less competition for
targets in the raiders receiving corps
Darryl Williams Bennie Snell or Gus
Edwards I'm gonna take the shot on
Darryl Williams because of the upside in
that Chiefs offense and I don't
necessarily think they're gonna go all
McCoy today David Johnson case Evans
Kaelin Bullough oh I am in pain from
reading that question I'll take a shot
on chase Edmunds I don't feel good about
any of those guys they're in pain he's
in pain I had a little blotch on my
throat I made you some soup oh what a
guy what kind of soup you like I don't
know check your noodle no that's split
pea pea that's like a Kaelin balázs of
soups right there yes we'll go chase
Edmunds next up here
Doyle or Rudolph just because we don't
know about feeling and we know that
Ebron and tu I Hilton are down we'll
play Jack Doyle today over to Kyle
Rudolph next up here Jets T or the
Panther C gotta go Panthers D pretty
good matchup for them so we'll go with
the Panthers the instead of the Jets and
Andy Dalton coming back Devo Samuel or
Keenan Allen and I'm playing Kevin Ellen
I'm not overthinking this I know sandals
been good a little bit banged up we're
just gonna play Keenan elegance the
Bronco sterling Shepard or cream hunt
flex PPR hey
clunk did it a couple weeks ago he's
getting the catches I'm a believer in
cream hun I told you could win you a
fantasy championship with a boost he's
on his way to doing that Steelers D or
the Ravens D I'll go Ravens at home
against the Niners now what am I going
to do
answer your questions in the app for the
next 30 minutes oh if I didn't get to
anything I'll jump in there I'll help
you out and you come back with us next
week we got two more shows to go here in
Vegas 8:30 Pacific 11:30 Eastern bit
more still coming out on Wednesday sleep
article Friday's the mailbag on Fridays
but most importantly I'm with you right
here every single Sunday morning on your
fantasy fire drill I'm Matt Kamp
good luck to you we'll see you next week
for the fantasy playoffs
[Music]